that's what Zach does so well he's so
good at writing
um
people I'm worried about you I want my
life back I want my child back this is
an incredibly special project and
obviously it was very special for Zach I
mean how did it feel for you to be a
part of this project something that he
wrote while working through his own
grief but then he also wrote
specifically for you
is it genuinely we had um it was it was
such a
a special time
special when he wrote it special when we
made it you know as he was writing it we
were we were going through the grief of
losing Nick so all aspects of of
everything that he needed to do to get
this film out of him what were happening
around us we were living in that time
where
it was immense darkness and yet through
you know the light of seeing our friends
and laughing with our friends made it
possible
I know people going through hard times
but with that they constantly find
levity and constantly find light and
then you know him writing for me it's a
it's a luxury yeah I've had it in the
past where people have written something
with me in mind to play that character
but he knows you I know but I've never
had someone write in the way that I
speak and the way that he knows that I
can push myself you know and he knows
how he knows my body of work he knows
who I am he knows my sense of humor like
he wrote it
truly with me on every page and and
obviously with Alison on every page and
then I came and breathed life into her
so it was um it made the whole process
it wasn't an easy character but it made
it so much easier stepping in you know
I'd cut so many corners I'd already done
the work of many months of chatting to
him about it and how fun was it
producing yeah you never been your first
feature film this is my first credit
how's it even possible
well it's funny when I when we were kind
of creating at the beginning we were
chatting about it and talking about it
and I was coming up with ideas and and
we'd be just discussing it I remember
one day turning to Zach and being like
you know I think I'm a producer and he
goes
um ah and I go no I think I'm a producer
I think I've been making some really big
decisions and I think I've been calling
some of my friends to be in the in the
in the film I think I'm a producer yeah
we've got to look forward to with you we
live in time I felt like the Oscars was
a preview of what's to come with you
anymore you know they didn't oh are you
kidding me I think that was accidental
no yes well I know beautiful accident
right there I know how much are you
looking forward to that project well
that was the first time that I met him
well I met him over Zoom like a few
months ago okay at the rehearsals it was
the first time that I met him so it was
like so relieving that it worked and we
got along and we laughed we could laugh
at everything and then of course on the
day I made so many like near mistakes
that he just saved me for and I was like
being true Spiderman you know exactly I
mean you were keeping great company
because you got Andrew Garfield then we
got London how about Zendaya Timothy
chalamet yeah uh Austin doing two girl I
know were you gonna take us for this I
have no idea whatever I hope I hope I'm
gonna wear some fabulous things though I
mean that red carpet is gonna be
bananas on fire
[Music]
foreign